فجروا كيف المظلم لضوء فيه سوارني قصف
مسيرات ثالث هجوم روسي في اقل من اسبوع
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه لقد لقالت السلطات
المحليه لكن الاضرار الماديه طالت البنت
التحتيه واغرقت المدينه وضواحيها في ليالي
حالكه الى كهرباء تتحدث روايه الاداره
العسكريه عن اسقاط الدفاعاتها 25 من اصل
عشرين مسيره نصدت في سمائك وكالعاده اتهمت
السلطات المحليه ايران بتزويد روسيا
بطائرات بدون طيار من نوع شاهد وبانها
اطلقت هذه المره من الساحل الشرقي لبحر
ازور عوده الهجمه الروسيه على كيف بعد
انقطاع عندما فتره هل ستغير شيئا في خريطه
المعارك المتاثره بالمناخ وبامور اخرى
خريطه لا تعرف تغيير لافتا يعزز جبهه طرفا
على حساب اخر
مزيد ثم المزيد من الاسلحه الجمله شبه
اليوميه للرئيس زيلينسكي وهو يدلي بتصريح
او يخاطب اجتماعا لحلفاء بلاده وما اكثر
الاجتماعات والقمم منذ نشوب هذه الحرب هذا
اجتماع الدول الاعضاء في تحالف قوه
الاستطلاع المشتركه الذي تقوله بريطانيا
ان عقد في ريغا بلافيا وفي جدول الاعمال
مناقشه جهود مواجهه العدوان الروسي الاحد
وصفهم قائمه مطالب الرئيس الاوكراني واضحه
دع بريطانيا الى زياده الامدادات من
الدفاعات الجويه والمساعده في تسريع
قرارات الشركاء في هذا الشان وطلب منه
هولندا تزويد بلاده بالدبابات خلال
المناقشات حتى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشي سوناتا قاده دول التحالف على الابقاء
على مستويات العام الجاري
اوكرانيا او زيادتها خلال عام 2023 مستوى
الخشيه من الاهداف غير المعلنه ل الرئيس
الروسي بلاطي مربوط اللي ماسك في هذا
التوقيت بلا عذر وتحت ضمن الوفد الرفيع
وزير الدفاع والخارجيه الصور التي نشرتها
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لمناورات عسكريه
مشتركه مع بيلاروسيا تعزز مخاوف الغرب من
انضمام قوات الحليفي لكشينكو الى الحرب
الدائره الامر ليس كذلك رد المتحدث باسم
الكربلا على الاصوات المحذره من ذلك
السيناريو وصف التلميح الى ان موسكو تضغط
على ميسك للمشاركه في العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه بانه فبركه غبيه الى اساس
وسوسو فرصه انهاء الحرب بالدبلوماسيه شبه
منعدمه والمواقف كقصى من طاقه مجمده لن
تذوب قريبا مسلسل حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا
مستمرا لغايه 2000 و 2023